let's go good morning
though right now we are in Big Bear
we're with the whole JK crew man over
there putting sunscreen on we are
getting ready to do the Spartan Race so
he's ready everyone is ready for from
sunglasses
I brought mine I became actually I'm
more ready than you are but I'm not that
ready to do the actual race because I'm
not very athletic me neither
and I'm actually I pedretti gonna so we
we signed up to the Spartan Race I think
like three months ago or maybe more cuz
Jia was still pregnant but yeah so we
signed up a long time ago and so now
we're here we rented this home in Big
Bear it's a really nice home by the lake
sort of not really we don't have a lake
but it's really pretty and so we got
here yesterday the race is today we're
gonna be leaving right after the race
because we have to go pick up Isaac
because today is a Sunday tomorrow he
has school so she didn't come with us
he's he's with his daddy yeah so we're
getting ready to do this thing and we
lined up the whole the cars cuz
apparently after we're gonna be
everybody crazy mess we're gonna be so
muddy I guess we have to go through mud
and water and I don't know but I'm ready
to just walk this whole thing cuz I'm
not trying to actually a high cost
Spartan Race for a reason I know 300
rolling deep ain't nothing but baby look
at you you've been working out huh yeah
but not for this dough it's been working
out for physique purposes man look at my
sexy mane
but yeah all right we're gonna be
heading out now i'ma show you guys the
inside of the part of the plastic bags
everywhere so we're prepared for the
mess you guys ready yes our first time
some Westside you guys ready hell yeah
thank you
yeah okay I'm just like waving my
deodorant put it on I'm ready we're
gonna really you've been awesome you're
gonna trip even bit a little checklist
for us which is really helpful thank you
I'm glad because I was looking it's like
man is it helpful like I don't know if
anyone used it but thank you for telling
I said we've inserted amber huh yes ever
is so adamant about my checklist and
then like and I like fell asleep at
midnight how slowly I don't know what I
need a pack you ready
oh yeah I did this yesterday
[Music]
you feel like you're really are the
military ship in ourselves off to battle
right now yeah no he's got pants I know
this leather is perfect if we're gonna
die today
myself dying perfect weather yeah it's
the most ideal because last year the
Spartan Race it was like somewhere
towards the mountains but like Forrest
semi-desert and it was just really dry
really does seem a lot it was like I'm
hundred and five degrees or something
but I heard that this race is like a
hard corner eight is it someone so Joe
is saying that this is a lot hard core
than previous no you're good you're good
you got to say every year hey we're
gonna pace ourselves and there's
teamwork Unit two so you can have this
remember healthy Oh perfect okay let me
carry you carry the whole race yes
[Music]
this is when we're still in good spirits
I hope this GoPro can hear me through
the underwater case first still in
really good spirits right now not so
much in the flowers stick with you okay
gasps ow
[Music]
anytime you cannot complete now how many
purpose you have to do how many 30
burpees that is correct I said sport is
repairable victory your spirit mind and
bodies not be pushed further than it was
not possible
once you jumped over that wall you it's
no turning back Who am I look little
spots are left to the right of you put
some punishment
[Music]
[Music]
no you're no quick team I can't even
lift my way to the finish line
[Music]
well crawl thingy wall helping you wall
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
back through this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]